welcome to Hannity we begin tonight a
Fox News Alert we begin with major
breaking news we were right yet again
look at this in a letter to the FISA
Court
the Department of Justice admitted that
at least two of their applications
against Trump campaign associate Carter
page lacked probable cause and that its
surveillance of page should not have
continued a stunning admission of guilt
that FISA abuse occurred illicit spying
occurred and the rights of not only an
innocent American were trampled but that
means all the spying on a candidate
transition team and president yeah that
was happening too but we first will have
all the details coming up at this hour
yep the liar from California is
continuing to foist himself on we the
American people here it is 9:00 p.m. and
the DC swamp 6:00 p.m. out on the west
coast and the Schumer ship sham show is
still going on after hours I mean this
is so painful and hours and hours of
mindless endless repetition babbling
here is what we learned today nothing
we've learned absolutely nothing zero
new revelations none no new arguments
zero no new developments whatsoever it's
the exact same Schumer ship sham show
over and over and over no now here's
what's getting interesting
what it's actually in a weird way will
do all the watching for you so you don't
have to suffer and will remind you every
night what's remarkable about this is
now running out of things to say so what
did they do after repeating themselves
endlessly because there's nothing new to
add well then they went back remember
they had hearsay witnesses and opinion
witnesses they brought back some of the
old testimony from the opinion witnesses
like the Harvard Law Professor that guy
he once wrote that President Trump
should be impeached for tweeting out the
phrase fake news he was brought back
today they rehashed old statements from
all of the hearsay of
piñon non-fact non-relevant witnesses
all that hate Trump are out political
disagreements they got so desperate
today to fill the time they even went
back and read from the Muller report the
one that vindicated President Trump now
I bet in talk radio for 31 years I love
my home my Fox home here in my 24th year
the yeah all these years I was a kid
listened and grew and grew up listening
to the Pioneers a talk radio Barry
Farber John Sawyer Barry gray Jean Burns
Jerry Williams David brought on all
these amazing people anyway and of
whatever I would listen constantly my
parents yelling at me all the times turn
the radio off and I didn't say okay they
go back in their room and turn it back
on again it and when a new host for
example you can hear this but you're
compelled to listen like you'll hear
hosts like all of a sudden okay well we
have one open law you know what it and
here's the number in three seconds later
here's the number here's it there are no
calls and they're struggling and I'd
hear it and it's painful to listen to
I've heard it many times a matter of
fact it actually happened to one guy
that we don't like on the show Alec
Baldwin this turns out to be the
greatest radio tape not on purpose he
was trying out he's tried out twice for
a radio show he walked out of one show
when it was me Mark Levin tag-teaming
him and he walked out then he went to
our my affiliate in Philadelphia WP HT
and we have the tape this is all real we
we're not making this up the best radio
in the history of radio listen when can
we take some calls Ivan do we have calls
that are on there now yeah no calls yet
what number do people call to get on the
air I mean do we have that number it's
right there no do I have the call number
in front of me oh I'm so sorry that's
interesting interesting where buddy
calls you out there Ivan no calls let's
beat some more about Scientology is Sean
hey Scientologists and Alec Baldwin
opposing the big questions tonight here
do we have any calls here yet Ivan none
boy it's just incredible now Danny had
his called his mother because nobody
called it's painful but in a sick way if
you listen to it you don't stop oh my
gosh this person is desperate that's
what makes it so bad it's that good I've
got to tip my hat to Alec Baldwin his
career in radio was not successful but
like Alec Baldwin what's happening in
the swamp Democrats they've run out of
things to say they don't know what to do
and they got another whole day and then
out mindlessly just repeating themselves
like a broken record take a look today
we'll go through article one the
constitutional underpinnings of abuse of
power we will show that president Trump
abused his power and abuse of power
abuse of power
peasant Trump had the motive the
opportunity and the means to commit this
abuse of power abuse betrayal and
corruption the abuse of power abuse the
presence
Trump's abuse of power abuse of power
abuse of power the president abused the
power of his office and executed his
corrupt scheme impeachment is justified
for serious abuse of power power power
power power power
they could say abuse of power all they
want doesn't make it true doesn't even
make it in teachable but remember the US
Constitution requires Oh
bribery high crimes misdemeanor treason
but this old you know the congenital
liar who's compromised in the case Adam
Schiff well it doesn't really care about
the Constitution instead of corded in
his own he's actually I'm beginning to
worry about this guy cuz he's losing it
his psychotic rage delusions and all the
lying he's done for three years I think
he believes he is like super Patriot
Comey he's protected in the country from
an imminent threat and he warned us a
Russian invasion take a look the United
States aids Ukraine and her people so
that we can fight Russia over there and
we don't have to fight Russia here
that's right
this is about Russia this you create
this whole thing is a Russia collusion
hoax it's alive and well like heaven
inside this guy's really psychotic sick
minds now forget the four separate
investigations that found zero evidence
including the Muller report that they
put all their hopes in Trump Russia
collusion is pathetically embarrassing
testimony Muller's on the capital hook
didn't even know what fusion gps has had
no idea Jeanne Ray Oh was Clinton's
attorney and worked for him
forget ship the congenital liar lying
lying like three years forget all
intellectual honesty common sense logic
and reason and take on spectacular
hypocrisy by ignoring quid pro quo Joe
and zero experience hunter forget that
the to sham articles of impeachment have
nothing to do with Russia or a quitter
or pro or quo because according to the
lunatics and their loony and the
Democratic Party they're all saying it
all of this is about Russia take a look
president Trump's campaign had welcomed
Russian assistance in 2016 the Russians
the Russians pushing Russian propaganda
Vladimir Putin not the Russians the
president wasn't pushing Kremlin talking
points just to do Vladimir Putin a favor
Russian propaganda
Russians Russia Vladimir Putin Putin
president nine states believes this
Russian propaganda against the advice of
all of his advisers to confront Russian
aggression Russian Russian Russian
Russian Russian Russia Russia's
confidence sadly is growing all the
green devyn noon has warned everybody
Russia is gonna interfere they did he
warned everyone in 2014 nobody listened
to Devin Nunez the Ukraine interference
election that was found by Ukrainian
court in January 11 2017 Politico read
their investigative report but now that
are back to Russia are you shocked the
Democrats appointed their top Russia
conspiracy theorist that guy Adam Schiff
the congenital liar to lead this case in
the Senate I can't keep a straight face
this same nasty degenerate lying through
his beady little eyes ever since he
slithered into the DC swamp that's
saying something he's the biggest con
man they're promised us for three years
he had top secret Russia more than
circumstantial evidence Trump Russia
collusion the same lunatic lied about
buys abused lied about the hearsay
whistleblower I wish we could talk to
him yeah they did and lied about Trump
zalinsky in the transcript and made it
up and lied about so call evidence in
the impeachment docs the same guy the
only one in the country and this is like
divine justice is the boomerang of all
boomerangs the only person that was
caught on tape talking to a Russian
thinking it was a Russian official
caught colluding with a Russian to get
dirt on Trump's who to affect an
election remember the one about
compromising materials take a listen and
she met with Trump and she brought him
one our Russian girl celebrity Olga
Basava who also known as a person with a
strange reputation Oh
who'sa what's the nature of the comfort
month well there were a pictures of
naked Trump and Boonton was made aware
of the availability of the compromising
material yes of course thank you very
much we will be back in touch with you
through our staff to make arrangements
to obtain these materials for our
committee and for the FBI and I
appreciate your reaching out to us
compromising my titties what's the
nature is a compromised pixels of the
neck naked to them and then a curtain
does water vir know that butter cause
look at me knows about the compromising
material that's almost as good as the
Baldwin taper toss-up right without a
doubt the congenital liar compromise
corrupt Adam Schiff is like the perfect
mascot for just how ugly radical
dishonest this do-nothing Democratic
Party is coming 285 days you're the
final juror oh thank goodness the
American people get to weigh in on this
you get to shock the world again I hope
you do his elaborate publicity stunt in
the Senate is a disaster
how do we know well thankfully to all of
you we mean this everyday you made us
number one in cable news by far again
last night
thank you we can't do it without you the
TV ratings are horrific ABC CBS NBC ABC
and CBS and NBC 1.2 million total
viewers that is an unmitigated disaster
with less than 300,000 in the quote keen
demo but they're sticking with their
regularly scheduled programs during
primetime of course they don't want to
lose any more money and earlier CBS News
they cut their impeachment coverage
short to run the soap operas let's get
back to making money American people
tuning out loudly they're not even
watching fake news CNN and conspiracy TV
MS you know Rachel Maddow is area 51
conspiracy channel and I'll watching it
the way you would think oh my gosh it's
impeachment most people know how this
ends that's why so lawmakers are
witnessing the Schumer ship sham show on
Capitol Hill according to the report
senators
chuckling to stay awake the best part of
all this Elizabeth Warren spotted
playing a game on a piece of paper Diane
Feinstein left the trial over an hour
early
area 51 conspiracy theorist there is
Roswell Rachel Maddow and her well panel
of conspiracy theorists they're angry
they're pleading now begging the
Democrats their friends in the Senate
please pay attention fake it fake
enthusiasm for the sake of the country
fake it Wow after all she's been lying
to her viewers for three years just like
the congenital liar first those Russia
collusion the hoax now she's filling her
viewers heads with these far-fetched
fantasies about Trump in Ukraine more
lies more propaganda more false hope and
our viewers are about to be let down
spectacularly all over again now unlike
MS DNC fake news CNN they're obsessed by
the way there are some guys on fake news
CNN humpty-dumpty in his I don't know a
Humpty Dumpty want to be some guy named
Oliver they stalk us as you focus on
their own failing Network and their own
Feli shows we have been right every step
of the way they should report that
tonight I could easily cut through all
the BS and tell you the truth now I'm
getting serious because this is hurting
the country funny but serious we know
how this ends we know the president will
be acquitted they are helping him at
this hour 45 Republicans are ready to
dismiss all these stupid charges by
doing some pretty basic math that means
there are not anywhere near the 67 votes
that would be required to convict with
just five more votes this charade will
immediately come to an end and now the
Democrats they have managed to offend at
least one of those swing votes and that
would be senator Lisa Murkowski
yeah I think Donald Trump helped Alaska
and with opening up oil there helps her
state hmm she's angry rightfully so the
house impeachment managers accuse the
Senate of a cover-up now you have
representative you have senators there's
a few weak Republican senators that are
probably still wavering you need to let
your senator know how you feel about you
at their decision here that they should
not be validating what has been a
corrupt
constitutional crisis that they are
putting this country to an ordeal it is
hurting the country these article of
impeachment is a farce it's all politics
they have hated Donald Trump and that's
all they've done every second minute
hour of every 24 hour day for three long
years and by the way no crimes no mister
mean there's no bribery no treason the
house didn't even bother to subpoena the
so-called witnesses that they're saying
the Senate must subpoena if you make a
crime out of going to the courts when
there's a conflict between the executive
branch and the legislative branch and
you go to the judicial branch and you
say oh we're booking executive privilege
which can be traced back to George
Washington you'd be destroying the power
of the presidency and spitting on the
Constitution that's serious and it's
clear that the Schumer ship sham show is
nothing more than partisan hackery and
revenge
they have been dreaming about
impeachment since 2060 and if I had time
I'd run the tape again Washington Post
announced that the campaign to impeach
Donald Trump began 19 minutes after is
inauguration tonight this insane
concocted political stunt they put this
country through for three years is long
enough how about working for the people
of this country is supposed to be public
servants do something to make us more
safe more secure more prosperous more
jobs do something this has got to end
the American people the ultimate jurors
you get to shock the world in 285 days
you will be the ultimate jury I hope you
shocked the world again and you don't
reward what they've done to this country
for three years because as we speak we
are watching a tale of two Americas here
you got the president racking up in the
last week and a half
one major accomplishment after another
look at these accomplishments record
breaking new trade deals 220 billion
dollars with China farmers manufacturers
Auto Workers energy sector service
sector Japan Europe Mexico Canada next
week is expected to release a huge new
plan in the Middle East you had a great
couple of days in Davos envy of the
world our economy record low
unemployment lowest since 69 every
American benefiting
every demographic one of the Democrats
done to improve the lives of anybody
nothing not a single solitary thing at
all they have not done a thing years of
psychotic non-stop rage hate